une trentaine de tweets dirigés à
l'encontre de l' empire du milieu
ce samedi 16 et dimanche 17 janvier
mike pompéo s'est montrée limpides quant
à ses relations avec le parti communiste
chinois
l'administration trump a mis fin à des
décennies d'apaisement et de politique
d'engagement malavisé envers le parti
communiste chinois
nous ne pouvons plus ignorer les
différences politiques et idéologiques
entre les etats-unis et la république
populaire de chine entre la liberté la
tyrannie un véritable tir groupé de la
part du secrétaire d'état américain
bras droit de donald trump depuis 2018
mike pompéo évoque chaque aspect des
relations sino-américaines des quatre
dernières années des relations
détériorées en l'espace d'un an
ma relation avec le président chine est
extraordinaire il est pour la chine
je suis pour les états unis mais à part
cela nous nous aimons signature
d'accords quelques jours plus tôt à la
maison blanche qui suspend la guerre
commerciale entamée deux ans plus tôt
baisse des droits de douane sur les
produits chinois achats de produits
américains pour 200 milliards de dollars
au cours des deux prochaines années
un processus d'apaisement miné par un
virus venu de chine le gouvernement
chinois ouvert aujourd'hui à toute
enquête virus de one le parti communiste
chinois la dissimuler le parti
communiste chinois a fait disparaître
les médecins qui savaient le parti
communiste chinois refuse toujours de
laisser entre le monde pour voir ce
qu'il a fait le parti communiste chinois
a menti sur l'origine du virus
la chine se conformera strictement aux
réglementations et exigences en matière
de prévention des épidémies et fournira
le soutien et les facilités nécessaires
pour que les experts de l oms puissent
se rendre en chine et mener à bien la
coopération internationale en matière de
traçabilité une question de passes
d'armes ces derniers mois sur plusieurs
sujets et sur fond de pandémie mondiale
en pleine campagne présidentielle donald
trump et son équipe ont davantage haussé
le ton vis-à-vis de la
in espionnage entreprises chinoises
placé sur une liste noire lois
sécuritaires imposées par pékin hong
kong décrié sans oublier le cas épineux
de taïwan
mike pompéo a annoncé la levée des
restrictions imposées aux responsables
américains dans leurs contacts avec
leurs homologues taïwan et la chine
s'oppose fermement à toute forme des
changes officielles entre les états unis
et taiwan la chine continuera à prendre
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
sauvegarder résolument sa souveraineté
et ses intérêts en matière de sécurité
certains hommes politiques américains
paieront inévitablement un lourd tribut
pour leurs déclarations et leurs actions
erronée un esprit de coopération
gagnant-gagnant dans l'intérêt
fondamental des deux peuples
déclaration de félicitations fin
novembre du président chinois qui espère
désormais de meilleures relations avec
le président élu joe biden lors d'un
débat présidentiel
ce dernier avait qualifié gidding pin
deux voyous